- [Nathan Voiceover]
If you're handing over
your computer to a stranger,
there's nothing you care
more about than your privacy,
so for computer repair shops
like Los Angeles-based Cyberguy,
earning customers' trust
is a huge struggle.
- We are saying them,
we are not gonna looking
at the files and folders,
or private files, but they don't
trust.
(soft piano music)
- [Nathan Voiceover] The reason
is
that most of us have
things on our computer
that we don't want seen.
As someone with a recurring
medical issue,
I keep photos on my laptop
that are meant only for my
doctor's eyes,
and when my computer breaks
down,
I can never be certain
that a repair technician
won't be tempted to snoop.
But fortunately for Cyberguy
owner Herman Akbiyik,
I had a solution.
- Your biggest problem is,
no matter how much you tell your
customers
you're not gonna look at
their nude or sexy pics,
they'll always be skeptical
because you're a sexual being,
right?
- Okay, so, whatever desire I
have,
it's not gonna be affecting my
business.
- What do you mean?
- Okay, if you don't eat foods,
you're hungry always, okay?
- Mm-hmm.
- If you eat food, you're gonna
be full.
You don't feel anymore your
hunger.
- Right.
- So if you don't
pleasure yourself at home,
maybe you're gonna feel it at
the office,
or while walking on the street,
you can feel those desires, in a
way.
- So you're saying you pleasure
yourself so much at home
that it doesn't affect you at
work.
- Correct.
(ominous music)
- [Nathan Voiceover]
Despite Herman's claim
that he gets everything out of
his system
before arriving at work each
morning,
his customers will never
completely trust him
because he's a sexual being.
But if Herman recruited repair
technicians
from the one percent of
Americans
who identify as asexual,
meaning they have no
sexual desires whatsoever,
customers could finally feel
confident
about getting their computers
repaired
without the staff being tempted
to look at their private photos.
The plan, put customers at ease
by offering the world's first
asexual computer repair.
- I see.
When they see any image, nude
image,
so they're not gonna be
desired or affecting?
- In theory, yes.
- In theory, I see.
- [Nathan Voiceover] Neither
Herman nor I
knew much about asexuality,
but he was willing to give it a
shot.
So I went to the internet's
most popular asexuality forum
and posted a job notification to
see
if anyone would fit the
criteria that Herman would need,
and later that week, I set up
interviews
with everyone who responded.
- You know, just the lack of
feeling,
a sexual attraction, and need
for sex,
is all that asexuality truly is,
and there's a spectrum to it
too.
- So if you're not thinking
about sex,
what are you thinking about?
- Well, it always depends.
I mean, I suppose, most of the
time,
I'm actually thinking about
superheroes,
my favorite of which being
Aquaman,
hence the orange shirt.
- So when most people are
thinking of sex,
you're thinking of Aquaman?
- Well, that's a funny way of
putting it,
but I suppose so.
- [Nathan Voiceover] After
learning more
about the asexual lifestyle,
I was feeling optimistic
that this could work.
- So right now, sitting across
from me,
you feel no sexual attraction?
- No, you're another person to
me.
- Whoa.
- I was born an asexual,
and I assume that I
shall still be an asexual
upon leaving this world.
- [Nathan Voiceover] So after
a rigorous vetting process
using a heart rate monitor to
judge
their physical response to a
series
of stimulating images I found
in a stock photo database ...
- Do you find this sexual
arousing?
- No.
- [Nathan Voiceover] I
offered the job to the two
who showed no spike in heart
rate
no matter how stimulating the
image was.
So the next day, I brought
the new recruits to Cyberguy
to introduce them to Herman.
- So this is Nicky and Randy,
and they're asexual, which means
they don't have a desire to look
at any customers' private
nudes or sexy photos.
You know, they just
don't have those urges.
- And also a sense of privacy, I
mean.
- Yeah, definitely, privacy is
important to everybody.
- Not because
of asexuality.
- Right, but someone like
Herman might be tempted.
- Yeah, possibility.
- Right, yeah, but you
wouldn't be tempted ever?
- No, no, no.
- Right, so that's why.
- [Nathan Voiceover] Their
lack of arousal was perfect,
but they still weren't computer
experts.
- I've removed viruses
from computers before,
but with instructions.
- [Nathan Voiceover] So
knowing they would need
Herman's close guidance
when doing a repair,
I installed a series of walls
in the back of the store
to create a quarantined
viewing booth for Herman
so the repair area would remain
free of sexual contamination.
The only access point
into the inner chamber
was through a military-grade key
code lock
that only the asexuals
would have the code to.
So after putting up a
brand new banner out front
and giving the repair staff
their code
to enter the desexualized zone
...
- The code is 1234, okay?
So don't tell Herman, okay.
- [Nathan Voiceover] The
securely sealed themselves
inside the repair area
while me and Herman waited
for customers up front.
- You didn't see the code,
right?
- No, I didn't.
- Do you promise?
- I promise.
- Okay.
- [Nathan Voiceover] Before
long,
the first customer arrived.
- It's very slow,
and it's hard for me to get
to the internet sometimes.
- [Nathan Voiceover] So it was
time to see
if he'd be impressed by the new
service.
- I don't know if you saw our
sign,
but we're the only computer
repair shop in town
that offers a fully
asexual repair service.
- Okay.
- Are you familiar with
asexuals?
- No, I'm not.
- Okay, so the entire time
your computer is here,
no one with any sexual
desires will be touching it,
and that is the Cyberguy
guarantee, right?
- Yes, for sure, 100% guarantee
that.
- Full disclosure, Herman
is a sexual person,
but he will not be touching
your computer at any point.
- What does that mean,
he's a sexual person?
- Yeah, that means, a
sexual person, as me,
so we having some desires
for looking at the picture,
digging, looking inside, so
we're curious
about what is inside,
what's contained inside,
it's a nude photos, videos,
stuff.
- So he has those desires.
- But the other people don't?
- They don't, the people
that will be repairing it.
- [Nathan Voiceover]
The first customer was
excited by the concept.
(bell rings)
- So now an asexual is coming
up?
- Yes.
- Got you.
(dramatic music)